[Applause]  and the oscar goes to  chivo  rita moreno at west side  live latin america  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  i can't believe it  oh my god they want me to talk because  i'm the worst english speaking guy here  this is pretty amazing it's a great  honor for me to have this i grew up in a  place called alcovendas where this was  not a very realistic dream  and i always the night of the academy  awards i stay up to watch the show i am  an immigrant  like alfonso and i'll handle my  compadres  like i like salma and like many many of  you muchas gracias alibo muchas graciami  familia muchas gracias mexico muchisimas  [Applause]  viva  gracias